[Music]
from the division of Warner Brothers
that still making good superhero movies
comes the adaptation of the best Batman
Joker story of all time which should
have been amazing but somehow ended up
including this wait is he with Batgirl
oh oh oh man oh it is so wrong on so
many different levels The Killing Joke
the joke is on us and this wanna be edgy
misfire that looks like a fan-made flash
animation and sounds like some of the
actors read their lines at gunpoint
hello I want to talk I'm sorry in a
movie that brings DC cinematic level
storytelling to the DC Animated universe
plus a dash of Lego Batman for good
measure
you haven't been taken to the edge yet
the abyss the place where you don't care
anymore we're all hope dies experience
the long-awaited adaptation of the 48
page comic with a 40-minute intro tacked
on to beef it up to feature-length where
is he that takes the greatest Joker
story ever told and adds all these new
non Joker characters like a generic mob
boss capiche
his dumb nephew with his dumb nephew
name his name is Paris Paris Franz
you're kidding and a 90s sitcom writers
idea of a gay person he's single and
they say the gang scene is complicated
in this below average extended episode
of the animated series that's trying
really really hard to justify its R
rating I don't think they could plug a
computer in their ass the badness [ __ ]
breathing down my neck can't quite make
out whether it's bums or rats but it is
god damn it fans love The Killing Joke
comic for it's twisted Batman Joker
storyline and criticized it for glossing
over Barbara Gordon's victimization and
torture now Warner Brothers is fighting
fire with gasoline by adding even more
Batgirl except now she also gets roofied
you've got maybe 10 seconds to bed
baby flirts with a criminal who's giving
her attention Oh baby
I think you've misjudged me has sex with
her boss complains about man he's been
avoiding me at least I think he is and
gets talked down to by a grown man in a
bad suit he doesn't know you
he's objectified you holy bets planning
Batman I thought we were partners we are
but we're not equals not even close
propping this strong female character to
just give up and quit and only then get
victimized in the exact same way as the
original source material so problem
solved
by creating many many many more problems
so if you've always wanted a version of
the classic Batman cartoon where bad
girls paralyzed and humiliated two of
your favorite characters have random
gratuitous sex and an iconic graphic
novel is ruined with a boring first half
that adds nothing to the story this
wasn't supposed to ten oh boy then we've
got the director video movie for you
also you desperately need to see a
therapist oh not her that's a whole
other set of issues
starring Batman and cradle-robbing Bratz
girl 90's gay best friend the red
triangle gang kilgrave and Six Flags
Gotham bad girl sex in the Gotham City
followed by The Killing Joke she showed
me pictures of my daughter have you seen
her
ooh that's gonna be an awkward talk be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers back in the 90s I was in a very
famous TV show
beware the demon chicken of doom man
what a bunch of Joker's the snozzberries
taste like snozzberries you get nothing
you lose good day sir I'm in pain and
I'm wet and I'm still hysterical we are
the music makers and we are the dreamers
of dreams